also here tonight as republican senator
of louisiana john kennedy
senator are you guys going to buckle to
big tech
well i read the letter orange and and i
understand
that the companies want to reform
america's immigration laws at least they
say they do
so do i the american people
deserve an immigration policy that looks
like somebody designed the thing on
purpose
the problem is that judging him by his
deeds
not by his words that's not what
president biden wants
president biden wants to basically erase
the difference between legal and illegal
immigration
judging him by his deeds not by his
words president biden thinks
that vetting people at the border all
people
vetting people at the border is racist
it's
not it's prudent
every country that i'm aware of does
that
i'll give you an example look at
president biden's two trillion dollar
coronavirus bill
he gives money to people
in his bill who are in our country
illegally well that's obviously
an incentive to people to come here
illegally
and a disincentive to people to follow
the rules
and if i could say a word about the the
coronavirus bill
president biden because we're going to
be taking it up tomorrow
president biden said in putting together
the bill he said we want to
we want to meet you us
the republicans halfway if that's the
case he's a damn poor judge of distance
he's rejected everything we've proposed
this feels
dreadful the only way i know how to
improve it
is with a shredder it's not even a
coronavirus bill calling this a
coronavirus bill
is like calling harvey weinstein a
feminist
it's chock full of spending porn
billions of dollars to states and local
governments that
have seen their revenues go up billions
of dollars to pension programs billions
of dollars to schools with no
requirement that they open
um it's it's a it's an orgy of pork
and and using a so-called coronavirus
bill as an excuse
to uh to fund pork is like looting
a natural disaster it's a bad idea so
senator i got to ask you this
sure you've had the opportunity to meet
zach zuckerberg
ceo of facebook does he care about the
kids in this country
being developed to go into this field
those young black kids
brown kids those white kids across this
country
that need the qualifications to get to
that point
to work in silicon valley why not invest
there i mean congress these state
legislators and they give all these
companies all these tax breaks
i don't think it's enough to say you
have to invest
in this country in our youth
well there's an old expression lawrence
you make a very good point by the way
as usual what you
do is what you believe and everything
else is just conversation
um i've said this before
jean-paul sartre a famous french
existentialist philosopher
had this theory that to be is to act
all we are is the sum of our actions and
everything else is just conversation
if you judge a lot of these uh large uh
tech companies by their actions and the
number of uh
people of color that are employed there
the number of females
then they fail the test i mean they
one of your the gentleman on before me
it's easy to go when you're making
billions of dollars a minute to go put
an ad
in the paper to say we believe in the
diversity
but you've got you've got to walk the
walk
not just talk the talk and that's that's
one of the biggest problems that i see
with them
it's all virtual signaling they they
post
the the black squares on instagram they
they give all the speeches they donate
to all the groups
but when it's time to actually take
action i mean the only thing that's
going to save our minorities in this
country
is economics that means jobs good paying
jobs
and they refuse and immigrants legal
immigrants in this country we celebrate
that apparently
they don't thank you senator thank you
lawrence